[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صفعه الاوسكار اوسكريه ما تزال تطن في اذن
التاريخ وكذلك الممثل الكوميدي كريس روك
هنا قرر روك ان يفك اللعنه الصفعه بطريقته
على منصه نتفليكس التي ضربت عصفورين بحجر
واحد
باعتبارها تجرب البث المباشر لحلقه
كوميديه خاصه خرج فيها الروك عن صمته لاول
مره منذ عام
قائلا انه تلذذ برؤيه النجم والسميث يتلقى
الضربات في فيلمه الاخير ايمانسبيشن مؤكدا
انه شاهد الفيلم فقط ليشفى غنيله من سميث
وفي كل مقطع يشجع على ضربه كان يقول اضربه
مره ثانيه وثمه مكان لم تضربه فيه [__] امك
وحرقه وروك الكوميديه الخاصه هي اول حدث
تنقله نتفليكس على الهواء مباشره حيث
تختبر المنصه هذه التكنولوجيا وتفكر في
التوسع في النقل المباشر لبرامج اخرى ووفق
مصادر مطلعه وافقت نتفليكس على دفع 40
مليون دولار مقابل حلقتين كوميديتين خاصه
اليها في عام 2016
والحلقه التي ضحك فيها الروك على سميث هي
الثانيه ضمن الاتفاق والتي اطلق عليها
الغضب الانتقائي كان قد بثها من مسرح
هيبودروم بمدينه بالتيمور